tierfreunde was geht ab herzlich
willkommen zurück zu einer weiteren
folge von rolex trader projekt endlich
geht es weiter und wir versuchen uns
heute durch pokémon karten so rolex
hochzufrieden das beste daran ist aber
dass nicht alle displays die ich in
diesem video gekauft habe für mich sind
der großteil ist für euch 72 evolution
bußtag werde ich an euch verlosen die
möglichkeit auf einen 5000 euro erholung
genug
wenn ihr wissen wollt wie ihr mitmachen
können wir gewinnen können dann bleibt
dran ich jetzt nicht gleich in den
letzten monaten ist der pokémon halt
komplett durch die decke gegangen ihr
habt es wahrscheinlich mitbekommen
komplett youtube sprich darüber
gestern abend war das team event von
primex und papa platte komplett krank
props an euch das war ein sehr sehr nice
die band nicht zuletzt ist der hype
natürlich dabei lagen proline first
edition display aufgemacht hat in tampa
platte einholung blu-ray gezogen hat das
mittlerweile fast sechsstellig oder
vielleicht sogar sechsstellig wert ist
und seitdem hat es mich und
wahrscheinlich auch komplett gepackt ich
bin komplett im film und guckt die ganze
zeit alle videos und jetzt ist es soweit
und ich will selber teil davon sein ich
hab dann während der planung für dieses
video die hilfe rufen und jungs
angerufen weil das letzte mal mit denen
so bock gemacht hat weil das so gut
funktioniert hat und weil die
glücklicherweise auch komplett im
pokémon halbwaren und wir haben uns was
sehr sehr krasses ausgedacht also
wirklich es wird komplett wir haben uns
entschieden 72 evolution booster an die
community zu verlosen und die in einem
fetten livestream auf zu machen
in den nächsten vier tagen habt ihr die
möglichkeit sich über den ersten link in
der video beschreibung die app
herunterzuladen und euch dort ins
gewinnspiel einzutragen 270 evolution
booster machen wir auch ihr habt die
möglichkeit auf dem 5000 euro hat ich
habe displays in perfektem zustand
gekauft das wird richtig zeit bis
donnerstag habt ihr zeit klickt auf den
link in der video beschreibung ladet
euch die app runter tragt euch da ein
das wird fakt ich danke den jungs
vielmals für die möglichkeit
ich bin zwar im high class pokémon
angeht aber es ist eigentlich für euch
was zurückzugeben einfach für den
support und weil viele von euch
natürlich auch im fieber sind und sich
vielleicht kein 1000 euro display oder
so leisten können wenn ihr die app
heruntergeladen haben awi geht einfach
in den news tab da findet ihr das
gewinnspiel tragt euch einen ihr braucht
keinen account
das dauert eine minute über den ersten
link in der video beschreibung findet
ihr die app ich will den jungs auch hier
noch mal riesig dafür danken letztes mal
haben wir fünf jahren 1 joker verlost
das war schon richtig fett aber dieses
mal wird komplett krank und ihr habt die
chance offen 5 carlo borer ich bin
wirklich normal gehalten macht damit am
donnerstag erfahrt ihr dann einen
livestream ob ihr gewonnen habe
und wenn ja was ihr gewonnen habt wir
den natürlich live gemeinsam auf machen
das wird komplett krank couscous und
jetzt weiter mit dem video perfekter
zeitpunkt zum einsteigen momentan sind
wir auf einem absoluten all-time-high
die karten sind so teuer wie noch nie
also wirklich schlechteste situation um
jetzt damit geld zu machen was soll's
ich will es trotzdem machen ich habe
bock booster zu öffnen aber als
allererstes brauche ich booster brauche
ich displays wo bekommt man hier also es
ist so gestört ich habe gerade
angefangen nach zwei displays zu suchen
also evolution displays da sind die
karten drin die quasi damals in den base
tab waren nur in neuer auflage mit ein
paar secret wars die quasi noch um top
kommen also sehr leise karten die je aus
seiner kindheit kennt aber die preise
sind komplett gestört mit 1000 euro muss
man pro display auf jeden fall rechnen
das ist natürlich auch denn den leuten
auf youtube geschuldet aber dadurch sind
natürlich die karten die sich in den
text befinden auch mehr wert aber ob man
damit profit machen kann
ich weiß es nicht trotz alledem werde
ich wahrscheinlich auf dem extra
evolution display geben
einfach weil die karten halt kult sind
ich hatte aber jetzt gerade noch eine
glaube ich ziemlich krasse idee und zwar
rufe ich jetzt bei allen läden aus
meiner heimatstadt an die damals schon
pokémon karten verkauft haben und frage
ob die vielleicht noch irgendwelche
displays auf dem lager liegen haben die
sie nicht verkaufen konnten
wenn ich das hinbekomme und die für
einen günstigeren preis haben kann weil
niemand kaufen wollte wäre das komplett
krank ok alle drei leben bei denen ich
angerufen haben wir im prinzip das
gleiche gesagt wenn pokémon karten oder
displays nicht verkauft würden wenn sie
zurück zum verlag geben die haben aber
auch gesagt dass der hype seit jahren so
konstant ist dass sie eigentlich nie was
zurückschicken und das immer alles
verkauft wird plus sie haben in den
letzten wochen vermehrt anrufe die main
gekommen wo leute danach gefragt haben
also die leute sind auf der suche
weil es halt einfach unendlich teuer
geworden ist das bedeutet für uns wir
müssen wahrscheinlich pro display 1000
euro ausgegeben hätten wir vor ein paar
wochen gekauft wäre es noch deutlich
günstiger gewesen aber jetzt ist es halt
so richtig in deutschland an
kommen und willkommen wahrscheinlich
nicht drum rum jetzt 1000 euro oder so
dafür zu brechen
wenn der profit machen ich wage es zu
bezweifeln
dazu auch noch wichtig sind top loader
das denn diese dinger hier wo die karten
einkommen und gesichert werden plus
leafs die bestelle ich auch sofort und
dann sind die karten die wir ziehen auch
sicher und wir können die vernünftig
einpacken außerdem hat sich jemand bei
mir per mail gemeldet er mir dabei
helfen kann die karte lädt zu checken
der mir vielleicht sogar dabei helfen
kann an karten ran zu kommen weil das
ist super wichtig in märkten wo super
viel geld da ist gibt es auch leute die
einen über den tisch ziehen wollen
genauso ist es bei pokémon karten es
gibt einfach komplett gefakte displays
komplett gefakte sets man kann jede
riskieren also die auspacken karten
rausholen wieder zu machen dieser markt
ist wirklich gerade eine komplette mess
weil einfach so viel geld da drinsteckt
pokémon ist das größte franchise jemals
mit über 90 milliarden umsatz insgesamt
das ist komplett krank und jetzt gerade
sind die leute halt bereit irgendwie
1000 euro für alte karten auszugeben
dann tummeln sich da natürlich auch
irgendwelche verbrecher die einen über
den tisch ziehen wollen aber erst um
seinen disco und seine pokémon community
pro gesagt greifen wir da unter die arme
den link zum disco ort um zu deren
twitter findet ihr in der video
beschreibung sehr sehr nette jungs die
mir dabei helfen dass ich eben nicht
über den tisch gezogen werden außerdem
kann der mir aus seiner eigenen sammlung
wahrscheinlich drei kann zur power boxen
und zwei trainer boxen organisieren das
sind genau dieselben karten dem
evolutions display drin sind diesen aber
robuster deutlich günstiger einfach weil
das natürlich nochmal geiler ist so ein
display zu haben aber wenn es einem nur
um die karten und ums öffnen geht dann
ist man eigentlich mit den karton power
und trainer boxen ganz gut beraten die
werde ich auf jeden fall nehmen der
macht mir ein super preis und jetzt
brauche ich aber noch zwei displays
jetzt könnt ihr euch fragen warum zur
hölle machst du displays auf das stimmt
also wenn ich eigentlich wirklich viel
geld damit machen will dann wäre es
vielleicht schlauer die karten zu traden
und nicht auf die glücksspiel schiene zu
geben displays zu kaufen booster zu
öffnen und für dieses display 1000 euro
oder tausende von euros auszugeben je
nachdem was es für 1 ist das stimmt das
ist richtig aber ich habe übrigens box
zu öffnen und es ist natürlich auch
content heinz da kommt also ich habe
tatsächlich einfach cottbuser zu öffnen
ich bin frohen format zu haben bei dem
ich so viele verschiedene bunte sachen
mit einbringen kann
seid mir nicht böse ist sehr
wahrscheinlich
sauer gewesen karten zu traden aber ich
habe einfach bock booster zu öffnen
außerdem setze und hoffe ich natürlich
auf meinen lack wenn wir ein paar gute
karten ziehen könnte es schon sein dass
wir mit plus rausgeben
aber da kommt es natürlich auf ein paar
faktoren an aber was sind die faktoren
im prinzip gibt es zwei faktoren die
einfluss darauf nehmen wie wertvoll eine
karte ist zum einen der zustand und dann
natürlich wie oft es die karte gibt und
wie begehrt ist an punkt eins kann man
relativ wenig ändern die karten sind
halt irgendwann raus gekommen
die gab es in begrenzter stückzahl und
gerade die alten sind jetzt schon mal
grundsätzlich im wert super cars
gestiegen also selbst wenn ihr niedrige
karte habt aus einem sehr alten set dann
ist die grundsätzlich schon mal mehr
wert als jetzt aus einem set was letztes
jahr raus kam beim zweiten punkt
wiederum können wir ein bisschen
einfluss darauf nehmen es kommt darauf
an wie wir die karten auf machen dass
die displays nicht beschädigt sind und
so weiter gehen wir mal davon aus dass
das display nicht beschädigt ist dass
die karten nicht geknickt sind und mit
dem boostern alles in ordnung ist dann
kommt es sehr stark darauf an wie man
die booster auf macht und wie man
allgemein mit den karten umgeht und wie
man sie anfasst gehen wir aber einfach
mal davon aus dass es alles passen wir
die vernünftig aufmachen dann kommt es
sehr stark darauf an wie die gedruckt
sind gibt es print lions also sieht man
verschiedene ungewollte linien auf dem
bild wo das pokémon abgebildet ist wie
genau in der mitte ist das bild des
pokémons hat das ein bisschen mehr
rechtsdrall oder bisschen mehr links
rein bisschen mehr oben bis hin nach
unten
das sind alles sachen auf die man keinen
einfluss nehmen kann die aber sehr sehr
wichtig sind für den wert der karte
also es ist nicht nur glücksspiel ob man
die karte bekommt die man gerne hätte
sondern auch in welchem zustand sie es
weil man auf ein paar faktoren einfach
keinen einfluss nehmen kann was ziemlich
verrückt ist und was dazu beitragen kann
dass man vielleicht gute karten zieht
die aber eigentlich gar nicht so viel
wert sind jetzt müsst ihr also grob wie
sich die preise zusammensetzen um dich
habe vor ein paar tagen die sachen
bestellt und dann sind sie auch schon
angekommen
ok freunde es ist soweit das erste
displays angekommen und zwar ist das
nicht meins sondern das von euch hier
drin befinden sich eure pokémon oh mein
gott ich bin so oft die condition
gespannt 1000 euro habe ich dafür
ausgegeben 36 booster sind da drin die
jungs vom buch gesagt haben ihr dabei
geholfen ein zu finden das wirklich
legend ist soweit man das über ebay
beurteilen kann es kam auch sehr gut
verpackt dann
es sieht so fucking alter mann sieht
sogar darauf das ziel im mit den pokémon
logos es sieht richtig gut aus 36
booster und in den boostern befinden
sich eure pokemon erster linie in der
video beschreibung ist wird neuer job
fucking ich bin so gespannt aber das
display sieht wirklich wirklich gut aus
ich glaube den karten darin geht es auch
wunderbar 1 von 3 es kommen noch zwei
weitere displays 1 für dieses video und
noch eins für den livestream und fürs
gewinnspiel von euch zu dem zeitpunkt
konnte ich mich schon fast gar nicht
mehr halten also wenn ich sofort in den
leistung gehüpft habe 36 booster das
komplette display geöffnet und das ist
dabei rumgekommen hauptsache dass die
booster halt nicht geknickt werden
wahrscheinlich traurig bin komplett im
film genau das durfte ich früher nie
haben meine eltern waren immer dagegen
dass sich pokémon karten kaufen
doha katar ist insofern hat kannst
kannst das schon richtig aufmachen
ok
energie carlos gardel das steht halt so
krass für mich für pokémon dass ich das
sehr sehr nah ist von der lieben packe
ich mal zur seite wir an die sehr sehr
ich weiß schon warum meine eltern das
mir damals nicht erlaubt habe und mein
gott ich habe gar nicht mehr drauf
geguckt ich war so gerade aber erzählen
muss schon noch muss schon noch knallen
alter aber dafür jetzt mein gott sieht
die krankenkasse tk hat schon sehr gar
als mittelalter in einem pack wieder was
war das für ein pech
man jetzt auch schon das einzige was wir
brauchen ist holbrookes aber sieht
fucking stick aus
ja ich packe die gleichen text um
youtube masala news so fucking sieg
warum jolo sehr sehr schicke karte
[Musik]
barockmusik
links macht
jetzt gewann muss
den mega trucks haben sich offen
die 25 nicht die hatten wir noch nicht
die hatten wir noch nicht als co
ich habe jetzt mal alle karten
aufgereiht die ich gestern abend ein
leicht hingezogen habe es hat so fucking
bock gemacht job ich kann euch nur raten
macht bei dem gewinnspiel mit es wird
fucking geil
das hier sind meine karten cherry
szabics plastics manche karten liegen
mehrfach aufeinander bei dem pikachu
sind das insgesamt sieben wir haben zwei
minuten auseinander liegen unter dem
text reverse und dem kommando reverse
liegen ganz viele normale rea card ganz
unten haben wir die kompletten secret
werk hatten die wir gezogen haben einmal
klein pikachu zweieinhalb pikachu
zweimal here comes team rocket wir haben
fast alles sieht wieder karten gezogen
wir haben einen jerry sah tags der
faschingszug aussieht meine absolute
lieblingsstadt die wir gezogen haben es
glaube ich der garage doors oder polo
extrem leise karten aber wir haben
natürlich noch eine rechnung mit den
displays offen wir brauchen ein hohler
blu ray und zwar eins für die community
man sagt ja so in jedem dritten pack ist
eins drin so faustformel ein pack ein
display haben wir aufgemacht aber keines
drin
das bedeutet es könnte sehr gut sein
dass in den beiden letzten 1 drin ist
wirklich tragt euch in das gewinnspiel
ein
das wird ein sehr neues event das wird
fucking sieg und ich habe es im gefühl
wir werden 1 für die community ziehen
aber die große frage die uns jetzt zum
schluss bleibt wie viel geld haben wir
gemacht oder wie viel geld haben wir
verloren wie viele sind die karten werte
die wir gezogen hat durch ankommen und
kommentars also kommando pikachu bluetec
so haben insgesamt 75 euro 50 gemacht
wie gehen von so standard marktpreisen
geradeaus für unbegründet karten in
gutem zustand so wie meine eigentlich
sind das alles ein bisschen schwer zu
sagen und das meer einen überblick als
dass es jetzt der wirkliche genaue wert
der karten ist es kommt halt sehr stark
darauf an ob sie gerettet sind wie sie
gekleidet sind und so weiter ich gebe
euch einfach nur so ein bisschen
anhaltspunkt damit wir wissen womit wir
rechnen können durch reverse hologramm
under und bluetec so die wir beide
einmal
haben wir 35 euro gemacht durch alle
unsere sechs karten also um youtube
cherry sagt ihr könnt das video ja vor
ein paar sekunden noch mal stoppen da
seht ihr alle karten haben wir insgesamt
155 euro gemacht und -roller karten sind
insgesamt 140 euro wert unseres sigrid
wer karten sind ungefähr 80 euro wert
und unsere karten also die beiden
youtube sind irgendwo so bei 20 euro
das ergibt eine endsumme von 505 euro
und 50 cent die ganzen anderen einzelnen
karten die wir jetzt gar nicht mit
aufgelistet haben wurden von meinem
kollegen auf 170 euro geschätzt das
machten insgesamt im kreis von 675 euro
und 50 cent was ca 325 euro verlust
bedeutet damit hätte man rechnen können
ich habe auch tatsächlich ein bisschen
damit gerechnet aber ich hatte einfach
die aufzumachen und das muss ich auch
nochmal ganz klar sagen es ist einfach
glücksspiel vergesst das nicht es macht
für euch wahrscheinlich relativ wenig
sinn außer ihr seid bereit wirklich geld
zu verlieren und euch ist das von
vornherein bewusst bei youtube stream an
ist es natürlich etwas anderes weil sie
damit content machen und das ja
eigentlich die haupteinnahmequelle an
den pokémon karten ist deshalb trotz dem
mega bock gemacht
ich glaube dass ich ein paar der karten
breaken lassen weil die dadurch halten
super viel mehr wert sind und ich glaube
dass meine in relativ guten zustand sind
schauen wir mal weiter wir gehen raus
mit 325 euro - was soll's wir sehen uns
nächste woche wieder cous cous cous